é é com muita honra que eu estou aqui
voltando essa região de fronteira onde
eu nasci para o jornalismo em 1991 e
onde eu quase fui morto por causa do
jornalismo em 2000 logo aqui do outro
lado da fronteira no paraguai onde me
deram uma boa sova e me largaram para
morrer na beira da estrada mas
finalmente realismo mente
acabei escapando estou aqui em anos
depois pra voltar e falar da importância
que a fronteira tem na minha vida eu sou
um cara de fronteira ou um cara sem
fronteira
dependendo sob ângulos se ver eu conheço
toda a fronteira brasileira essa
profissão que eu exerço já 29 anos é me
possibilitou isso uma experiência que
nem imagina que nenhum outro jornalista
ou nenhum outro brasileiro teve de
percorrer toda essa região de fronteira
28 mil quilômetros entre idas e vindas e
eu eu não posso deixar é deixar de falar
no fazer um comentário antes de entrar
no tema especificamente que também tem a
ver com essa região de fronteira do
orgulho que eu sinto como pai de ver o
meu filho e envolvida em um projeto como
esse junto com os colegas é um projeto
tão lindo que tem essa é proposta de
fazer difundir o conhecimento
então todos os estudantes da unila
envolvidos nesse projeto sim merece uma
salva de palmas que eu gostaria que
porque não é um empreendimento wassil 20
organizar um evento ainda mais um evento
assim desse porte com essa proposta com
esta marca é uma responsabilidade grande
então estão todos muito parabéns
bom eu queria já entrando então na
temática da apresentação falar um pouco
de um património imaterial da humanidade
a mentira a mentira é um patrimônio
imaterial e eu vou trazer aqui alguns
exemplos e ao final da apresentação é
falar um pouco sobre alguns escapes em
alguns é algumas alternativas para
escapar desse engano que está tão
presente ao longo de toda a história da
humanidade
então agora em 2016
a revista nature neuroscience publicou
uma pesquisa muito ampla realizada nos
estados unidos mostrando como nós o
nosso cérebro ele se adapta a mentira as
alguns enganos as fraudes né
e começa de pequeno e vai a gente vai se
acostumando vai na naturalizando ea
gente não só comete como a gente aceita
com naturalidade a mentira e vamos ver
ao longo da história como eh eh eh eh eh
ela esteve muito presente ela morreu
mundo ela ela construir um mundo ajudou
pelo menos a construir o mundo como ele
é hoje unit ele diz que a mentira
necessária pra gente conseguir superar a
aspereza do dia a dia
o andré comte-sponville wheelie entende
que sendo a boa fé é uma virtude a
mentira em oposição não deveria ser mas
ele mesmo reconhece que nem toda mentira
emma é existe em mentiras de boa
intenção eu vou procurar trazer alguns
exemplos aqui o jorge se meu
ele diz que a mentira é parte do
processo de comunicação ou seja a
mentira está presente no processo nas
interromper inter relações sociais
porque nós nunca sabemos é o que se
passa na cabeça de um ou do outro ea
mentira para ela dar certo ela tem que
ser uma exceção é nós há naturalmente
uma pessoa mente uma vez uma segunda vez
uma terceira vez pra gente uma quarta
não vamos acreditar então ela funciona
porque ela é uma exceção e não
uma regra é e mas a mentira tão presente
no cotidiano nessas relações
talvez não não recordem o nome desse
sujeito o carlos rhode mas o personagem
que ele criou e trouxe ao mundo em 1883
certamente todo mundo já leu ou ouviu
falar dele que é o pinóquio porque é e
uma mensagem implícita no ué no
personagem pinóquio é como a mentira
pode fazer mal para as pessoas que a
gente ama é uma mensagem de fundo na
história do pinóquio mesmo que seja é
boa mentira de infância porque na
psicologia se estuda ea mim é mentira
como uma forma a criança já desde
criança a criança já desde o início
perdão ela é mente por algumas razões
para escapar de algum enrascada ou para
conseguir algum objetivo
então mesmo nos lá nos nossos é no
início da nossa vida a gente usa desse
artifício mesmo de uma forma
inconsciente que isso pode produzir mal
pra ganharmos alguma coisa ou evitarmos
um dano e é nós temos duas correntes
filosóficas que tentam explicar é o
nosso comportamento as nossas ações no
mundo
nós temos por exemplo a ética
deontológica do cante e nós temos a
ética teleológica que seria a ética
utilitarista do dinheiro inventam a
ética deontológica do cante ele que ela
diz que a ação é é o valor moral da ação
reside nela mesmo e não na consequência
que se espera dessa ação ou seja devemos
agir dessa maneira porque assim o
correto a se fazer
já ética utilitarista do dia mb tam e aí
a gente teria que ampliar o a
compreensão de como o bank criou essa
teoria
é no no período pós industrial na
inglaterra em que havia 11 se sistema
higienista né
é em curso e aí ele produziu essa teoria
que justifica exatamente a mentira o que
essa ética é utilitarista ou seja
conseqüência lista a minha são ela vai
ter um valor dependendo do resultado da
consequência que ela terá
e se no meio do caminho eu precisar
mentir pra alcançar esse objetivo não
tem problema desde que essa consequência
vai produzir é a felicidade de um maior
número de pessoas
mas aí é um problema subjacente a essa
ética utilitarista ou teológica que é
seu pretendo justifica os meus atos são
justificáveis para atender aos
interesses a felicidade de um grande
grupo isso significa que eu posso violar
os direitos de minorias e aí por isso
que ela se opõe à ética deontológica do
cante que não prevê em hipótese nenhuma
mentira mas a ética kantiana ela é tão
curta que não permite a mentira sobre
qualquer hipótese nem pra salvar a si
próprio nem pra salvar a vida da própria
mãe
então ele refuta a mentira sobre qual
quaisquer condições
então temos duas situações opostas ea
gente nota é no nosso comportamento
cotidiano que a gente muitas vezes mente
para atingir algum objetivo é evitar
algum dano é só basta gente nós mesmos
fazemos uma revisão da última semana
quem disser aqui que não cometeu nenhuma
mentira em uma semana ou duas semanas
possivelmente estará mentindo é porque
ela é esse e é esse bem imaterial
património imaterial da humanidade
o galileu galilei por exemplo
ele teve que mentir é ou resultar a sua
descoberta heliocentrista é pra poder
salvar a própria vida então numa
oposição ao que o cante diz se fosse uma
visão kantiana é extrema
o galileu galilei ele deveria ele
deveria manter sustentar a sua teoria
heliocentrista e seria muito
possivelmente morto em alguma fogueira
ele não poderia então mentir para salvar
a própria vida e é ela está tão presente
na constituição da sociedade ocidental
a mentira que ela está presente
inclusive no 8º mandamento que diz 8º
mandamento não levantarás falso
testemunho mas a gente vê que mesmo os
mais eméritos eleitos de deus também
tiram ea mentira que eles contaram
dentro da alegoria alegoria bíblica é é
as mentiras que esses méritos eleitos de
deus cometeram foi fundamental para que
a sociedade chegasse no estágio de hoje
pegamos um exemplo de adão e eva que
tentaram mentir pra deus se não tivessem
é provado do fruto proibido nós por
consequência não existiríamos estão
dentro dessa alegoria da bíblia o abraão
abraão o pai das três religiões
monoteístas judaísmo cristianismo e
islamismo mentiu por duas vezes uma
diante do faraó do egito outro diante do
rei
a bíblia lex porque a sara sua esposa
era tão bonita que ele tinha medo de ser
morto pra quê farol ou rei a thomassen
dele então pediu a ela que mentir se
dissesse que era irmã dele
isaac já corre e davi também criaram a
sua verdade provisória para fugir de
algum escapar de alguma situação
inconveniente
é pedro também mentiu ao negar três
vezes jesus ele mentiu e eu estou
dizendo trazendo isso quem sou eu pra
condenar essas figuras bíblicas que
norteiam a espiritualidade de milhões e
milhões de pessoas no mundo não é eu num
trabalho esses exemplos como uma forma
condenatória
muito pelo contrário é pra dizer que a
mentira está de forma tão presente na
nossa vida que se pedro não tivesse
negado cristo a gente pode supor o que
teria acontecido com ele possivelmente
seria crucificado também o sofrido
alguma punição e pedro é o assegura
basilar da construção do cristianismo no
mundo né
é o platão ele via vir via mentira como
uma virtude quando ela poderia ser usada
por um governante em benefício do povo
maquiavel ampliou essa discussão porque
ele entendia que todo homem é mau e aí o
princípio ou seja o governante ele teria
também ele poderia usar instrumentos
como a mentira pr'a se sustentar no
poder
então é daí advém desse o termo é
maquiavélico enfim que é que sustenta
essa discussão em torno do comportamento
dos políticos e alguns políticos ou
príncipes na visão de maquiavel levar um
cd de forma é tão ao extremo a exemplo
de hitler e stalin que mentiram e muitas
ocasiões para justificar as suas acções
né
toda a propaganda nazista baseada na
mentira contra o povo judeu é toda
aquela propaganda foi baseada na mentira
pr'a dizimar ou tentar dizimar esse povo
né
é em 2003 nós tivemos o caso do george
bush e tony blair que inventar uma
grande lorota uma das maiores lorotas da
atualidade de que havia armas armas
químicas que jesus pra justificar a
invasão do iraque e deu aquela desgraça
toda a gente soube e que ainda teremos
conseqüências até hoje o surgimento do
estado islâmico e outros grupos
terroristas se dá muita razão é muito em
razão disso o otávio paz no bell de
literatura de 1998 e tem também uma
frase lapidar sobre isso é uma mentira
políticas se instalou em nossos povos
quase constitucionalmente e o dano moral
tem sido em calculável alcançando zonas
mais profundas do nosso ser
morremos na mentira com naturalidade é
não sei se vocês têm noção mas existem
institutos nos estados unidos que medem
que fazem o facto tchequi de tudo que o
trump disse e ele mente em média 12
vezes por dia
não sou eu que estou dizendo isso são
vários e institutos nos estados unidos e
ea imprensa de lá costuma cobrir com
freqüência 12 vezes em média por dia
isso contando sábado domingo feriado ou
seja ele é um mitômano incansável
incorrigível né
é isso tudo obviamente ele mente pra
justificar as suas ações a exemplo do
muro né é na fronteira do méxico e tudo
mais
agora eu queria entrar especificamente
naquilo que eu queria falar pra vocês
como uma alternativa um escape às
mentiras
eu há pouco me perdoe a pessoa eu estava
sentado logo no início antes do início
das apresentações aqui eu estava sentado
ouvindo uma pessoa dizer comentando com
outra que não assistia tv porque os
jornais publicam só o que eles querem
isso me fere me doeu demais eu vivo
disso a 29 anos né
é então é uma pena que tenha muita gente
que acha que os jornalistas 30 40 100
jornalistas dependendo a aaa ao tamanho
da redação que vá para o trabalho
pensando puxa o que não quer que
normalmente hoje quem nós vamos sacanear
é que informação nós vamos manipular né
existe a manipulação sim porque a
verdade no jornalismo não é a gente não
alcança a a a verdade e instância
nenhuma né da nossa vida e não seria
diferente no jornalismo porque nós
pegamos aspectos da realidade que nós
podemos alcançar com os nossos sentidos
né
é um exemplo quando o ex presidente luiz
inácio lula da silva
ele acabou sendo preso né na no âmbito
da operação lava-jato duas manchetes
clássicas o jornal o globo trouxe lula
preso
lula é preso e no jornal do brasil lula
se entrega o natal mesmo mas temos aí
duas verdades uma verdade que o jornal o
globo que isso é uma verdade semiótica
uma verdade que o jornal o globo queria
levar uma verdade que o jornal do brasil
queria levar através da sua mensagem
então acontece de haver manipulação pode
acontecer mas é existem estudos num
efeito exatamente no nos estados unidos
também que mostram que o jornalismo é
uma instância onde a gente pode buscar
elementos de verdade sobretudo em
sociedade como essa em que nós vivemos
de pós verdade e de ver que news
então com isso eu gostaria de agradecer
o convite aqui dizer que é isso que eu
tinha pra falar com vocês brigado
[Aplausos]